merci question 560 de Monsieur René Paul
Savary à monsieur le ministre du Travail
de l'Emploi de la Formation
Professionnelle et du dialogue social
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je voulais attirer votre
attention sur l'Allocation de Retour à
l'Emploi et plus particulièrement
lorsque une personne travaille et donc
des revenus tirés d'une activité réduite
je prends un cas particulier qui se
trouve en fait devenu devenir une
généralité pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens une marnaise était en
contrat unique d'insertion à 20h par
semaine depuis septembre 2012 et lorsque
cet agent a réalisé son travail mensuel
de septembre à novembre 2012 sans heures
complémentaire elle a perçut 669 euros
nets de son employeur et 180 euros
d'allocations de retour à l'emploi
versée par Pôle emploi soit un montant
de 849 euros
occasionnel ou réduite reprise ou
conserver peut bénéficier parallèlement
à son salaire d'un maintien partiel ou
total de cette allocation bien entendu
le salarié ne doit pas travailler plus
de 110 heures par mois surtout pas plus
et les revenus qui lui procurent son
activité réduite ne doivent pas excéder
70% de son salaire brut mensuel surtout
pas plus également alors pour en revenir
à notre site Web marnaise en contrat
unique d'insertion elle n'a pas dépassé
le seuil des 110 heures mais le revenu
que lui a procuré son activité réduite à
xéder le seuil de rémunération déterminé
donc c'est en travaillant plus qu'elle a
gagné moins pouvez-vous m'expliquer
monsieur le ministre ce que vous comptez
faire pour éviter ce genre de situation
qui n'est pas unique mais qui est plus
répandu qu'on ne le croit et qui se
révèle être là plutôt un frein à
l'emploi qu'une incitation
merci monsieur le ministre
ce Président Mesdames sénateurs
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Savary vous avez déjà la
réponse donc je vais vous faire une
réponse j'espère qu'elle vous amènera
quelques compléments réponses que vous
avez déjà à l'esprit ou en tout cas que
vous pensez au respect
la réglementation actuelle de
l'assurance chômage permet avait dit le
cumulus partiel d'une rémunération et de
la location d'aide de retour à l'emploi
de façon à ne pas désinciter à la
reprise d'un emploi ce dispositif
d'inactivité réduite autorise ce
cumulent dès lors que cette activité ne
dépasse pas sa misère par mois vous
venez de le dire et ne procure pas plus
de 70% des revenus antérieurs en outre
la durée de ce cumul est limitée à 15
mois
ces plateformes peuvent parfois induire
des effets de seuil qui interroge ou qui
nous interroge pour autant la définition
de la réglementation d'assurance chômage
relève de l'entière responsabilité des
partenaires sociaux gestionnaires du
régime et la renégociation de la
convention inédite débutera dans les
prochaines semaines lors de la
négociation de 2011 des signataires
c'était entendus pour affront
approfondir au travers d'un groupe de
travail certains enjeux au titre
desquels figure l'activité est réduite
aussi il y a peu de doutes que la
réforme dispositif sera un des points de
la future convention afin d'en améliorer
la lisibilité et renforcer son caractère
incitatif au retour à l'emploi
merci Monsieur Savary
oui merci monsieur le ministre des
Anciens Combattants c'est pas votre
spécialité mais je vois que vous avez
travaillé le sujet je vous en remercie
effectivement c'est l'effet de seuil qui
est particulièrement pénalisant à chaque
fois je crois que il sera intéressant
qu'on puisse se pencher sur cette
question et faire des propositions que
vous puissiez au niveau du gouvernement
faire des propositions à nos partenaires
sociaux parce que je crois que à travers
ce type d'exemple on pénalise
véritablement ceux qui sont déterminés à
s'engager davantage dans l'emploi donc
il nous appartient
au niveau où nous sommes de prendre les
mesures permettant que nos concitoyens
comprennent les lois et les mesures
qu'on leur propose merci
merci question 557 de Monsieur Michel
Bilou à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale